[Applaudissements]
tu peux respirer un peu
[Rires]
j'ai vu j'ai vu des gars voilà
plein plein
de discussion avec la silice j'ai dit à
tout moment ça peut exploser parce que
là je suis bien je suis compressé pas
mal les petites bottines
[Rires]
sur vous c'est pour ça tu as beaucoup de
bruit
je suis pas pour la mode
est déjà 8h pour l'enlever
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
merci pour l'accueil en tout cas merci
vous voulez qu'on parle de votre tenue
mais c'est vrai que là c'est vrai que je
suis pas bien le bouton là
ton frère il y en a un qui va se le
prendre dans la course
[Applaudissements]
j'ai un petit cadeau pour vous est-ce
que vous voulez sanctionner le retard de
Mathieu Delormeau
alors on le fera dans un instant on
commence d'abord avec vous puisque Cyril
vous étiez très très agité cette semaine
et du coup on a voulu faire une petite
slot à méchouia de toutes vos bêtises de
toutes vos gueules déjà dans direct
c'est tout simplement la semaine de Baba
c'est beau très beau
c'est un vire peu particulier
comment ça va voilà j'adore
[Musique]
j'adore
puis fin 2020
cette semaine vous avez pris un vent de
force 8 mais en même temps c'était un
peu prévisible
non c'est rare la loi de bonjour
salut Anthony salut mon chéri merci
d'être là merci d'être là
mais ne rien [__] c'est vraiment une
des conditions pour avoir peut-être le
dire aux gens qui travaillent
[Applaudissements]
je pense
je pense qu'on va remettre le bail avec
Anthony je pense que ça y est ça rentre
dans le top 3
remettez-le
bonjour salut Anthony salut mon chéri
merci d'être là merci d'être là Anthony
[Rires]
un ancien nouveau ancien nouveau ancien
nouveau chroniqueur autour de cette
table c'est Jean-Michel Jean-Michel mer
quelle est la particularité de
Jean-Michel
il est fidèle c'est vrai mais en plus
d'être fidèles il en fait des caisses
des caisses des caisses des caisses des
caisses excellent on commence avec
Jean-Michel Vito
c'est le mode traîne dans les toilettes
et montre-moi ton gros rat montre-moi
ton gros
on continue avec Jean-Michel la lourdeur
la grosse lourdement
[Rires]
on poursuit avec Jean-Michel cavier
aujourd'hui
tu parles toujours fort comme ça
et on termine avec Jean-Michel Pôle
emploi et Daniel toi quand tu arrives et
tu mets bises sur le téléphone à
l'ancienne pour savoir le dernier numéro
[Applaudissements]
je l'adore j'ai ouvert parce que là
je suis heureux
si est-ce que vous rappelez de cette
séquence avec cette proposition de de
scénario que vous aviez reçu bien sûr
vous rappelez on regarde j'adore
est incroyable le film démarre et c'est
un gars je pense c'est ralphine il a
tout perdu et il essaie de mettre fin à
ses jours il n'y arrive pas parce qu'il
a pas le courage il va avoir un pote à
lui
qui connaît des voyous et il me dit
trouve-moi un gars un tueur à gage qui
va me tuer le problème c'est quoi il
trouve là c'est que il trouve la
merde
bon alors on disait avec Cyril que cette
proposition de scénario que vous avez
reçue si c'était possible que ça existe
alors selon les chroniqueurs pas du tout
sauf que les chroniqueurs vous savez
quand ils voient Cyril ce sont des
fayots on peut le dire ce sont des gros
focus certains regardez Cyril pendant
les pubs ce qu'on dit les chroniqueurs
sur cette proposition de scénario c'est
pas la même chose
la folie merci beaucoup les chiens vous
vous devez vous étiez un petit peu
merci
ça existe déjà je vois que c'est un
espèce oh là là là non mais bon
ça fait plaisir à Jean-Michel et je peux
faire des amis je la connais non mais
sérieux
cette semaine vous avez joué avec les
téléspectateurs oui ils ont dit que ça
existait mais c'était du plagiat quoi il
vous accuse de plagiatures
mais la chute c'est qui vous accuse de
plagiat moi je pensais que vous avez des
défoncer derrière c'est pas ton meilleur
ami du film fallait pas de vérité moi ok
je vais mettre un 49-3 sur ta chronique
cette semaine vous avez joué avec le
télévisateur au jeu de logique vous
savez bien sûr il y a une chose que vous
détestez Cyril par-dessus tout vraiment
par dessus tout quand on triche c'est la
triche c'est des tests ça et Cyril
l'avantage avec lui c'est qu'il déteste
un triche donc du coup il triche jamais
enfin
[Musique]
quelle proposition est correcte la a la
B ou la
CI
puisque c'est un carré vert dans un rond
bleu c'est ce qui se passe c'est bien
sûr pas de vrais triche juste un petit
regard sur la fiche c'est normal
heureusement pour la deuxième question
vous avez été honnête vous allez
regarder la fiche combien y a-t-il de
cible
identiques top chrono
bien sûr bien sûr vous n'avez vraiment
pas besoin et donc une fiche pour
répondre à ces questions le regard est
incroyable sur des Français
quelle lettre remplace logiquement le
point d'interrogation
exactement
oui exactement Cyril vous n'êtes pas du
tout un tricheur chef par contre vous
êtes de très mauvaise foi mon code
contient deux chiffres commençant par
une voyelle et deux chiffres commençant
par une consonne quels sont les deux
chiffres qui doivent remplacer les
points d'interrogation top chrono la
réponse est sous vos yeux regarde
derrière il faut deux chiffres comme
réponse
il a vu l'émission je te jure que non il
y a eu un et c'est le seul chiffre qui
commence par une voyelle et de chiffres
qui consomme 6 et 2 CD voilà on a
compris
[Applaudissements]
c'est magnifique
vous savez que je faisais la même chose
en classe la prof elle va me cramer je
regardais sur le truc madame je le
connais je vérifie juste
il est bon voilà c'est tout
tu passes qui avait après mais c'est pas
possible d'avoir des tanches pareils
mais moi je suis l'animateur c'est
normal que j'ai des réponses
semaine prochaine c'est ce qu'on va
faire je vais me mettre là il y en a un
qui va animer vous avez posé la question
là je les aurais pas mis oreillette ni
rien du tout vous allez voir
on peut le faire demain
on fera demain en direct vous allez voir
vous allez en prendre plein la gueule
pourquoi tu vas déglinguer
j'ai déjà donné
mon pote on
sait combien
il arrive 13h15 aux émissions il l'a
prouvé encore aujourd'hui vous êtes
d'accord pour le sanctionner oui
sauf que quand on arrive parfois en
retard Cyril ça peut créer des problèmes
dans les émissions télé
en étant direct les chéris et j'ai plein
de choses à vous dire qu'est-ce que tu
fais toi t'es pas équipé tu sors tu vas
t'équiper tu reviens tu vas être équipé
tu reviens allez vas-y mon bébé et tu
m'enlèves cette vilaine veste
Mathieu pardon que se faire mettre un
micro et en profite pour vous mettre une
grosse cartouche Cyril mais un micro bah
ça enregistre tous c'est Mathieu vous
devriez le savoir c'est la télé
[Applaudissements]
non t'es pas trop non
mais que tu es qui pue le mec là tu vois
pas quand tu entends c'est vrai
qu'on a tout entendu le je t'emmerde
aussi et là il se chie dessus
pourquoi je te le dis la veste
[Applaudissements]
comment j'aurais pu dire ça
il veut ma place
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes très généreux vous avez voulu
récompenser le petit nouveau sur C8
Jordan Deluxe pour ses audiences sauf
que bah comme j'ai dit c'est un petit
nouveau et s'y connaît pas trop bien
Baba encore et c'est surprise vous
l'avez vous avez voulu le faire kiffer
maintenant Mylène Farmer son lit
presque fin non non franchement il lui
ressemblait de ouf regardez bien
regardez bien la déception dans la tête
de Jordan Deluxe et regardez bien la
tête de Cyril c'est exceptionnel
ce soir
Jordan
pour tes 104000 pour ton record elle est
là Mylène Farmer non
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
la démarche et tout c'était la d'autres
trucs avant de repartir
on va revenir sur hier événement
international sur ces mythes pour
recevait Afida Turner et à chaque fois
qu'elle vient on peut le dire c'est un
show exceptionnel alors est-ce que vous
souvenez de la dernière fois on s'était
arrêté sur les réactions des gens dans
le public et des chroniqueurs quand
tafida arrive et fait son
nana et bien on a recommencé cette fois
c'est plus un choc les gens sont
abasourdi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
plus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au bout
de combien
[Applaudissements]
merci la fille